all right here's the here's the big
story of the day the first thing I want
to say uh you know Trump let me read the
title for you Trump's red hand markings
draw wild speculation including syphilis
conspiracies and so here's the uh let's
open the image so you can get a better
view I'm going to be honest with
everybody so we're we're sitting here
getting ready for the show and I'm just
like there really is no news today and
you know one of the top stories on The
Daily Mail is like horses pull SUV from
ditch and I was like
what is this not news but man they're
really grasping and so the people who
hate Trump are running out of things to
hate Trump about so when Trump waves and
he's got blisters on his hands which are
clearly golf blisters there's no other
explanation I mean maybe he felt fine
whatever but you can look at where
they're at clearly from gripping a golf
club golf blisters are extremely common
these are the stories that they decide
to run could Donald Trump have syphilis
they say former president Donald Trump
was photographed Wednesday leaving his
Manhattan apartment with Patchwork of
red markings resembling blisters on his
right hand drawing Mass speculation
about the cause of the apparent
Affliction As Trump has stayed
uncharacteristically mum on the
subject what to say like well do you be
not mum about do you think we'll ever
get to the point where we elect a
president that openly has syphilis I
mean that's my question we just taking
away no no in order for Trump to have
had progress in syphilis to that degree
it would mean that he had symptoms for
like 10 years okay so or like so you
don't think we'll ever be like this
President will be like I have syphilis
and I should lead the country it is an
entirely curable disease I don't know
what if youma you can get some what is
it like antibiotics or something but I
want to say this is why people hate the
media and don't trust the media because
this is this is basically the lead story
of the day which is ridiculous it really
is look like James Carville is talking
about MSNBC is talking about it do you
think that's people are though I feel
like this is easier than the other
that's going on right now aliens are in
their spaceship above the Earth and
they're about to press the make first
Contact button and the story popped up
and then the other alien pushed the hand
away and said no there not not not these
people get behind me Satan no these
people are no good we're we're eject and
then they leave we're not going to bring
them into the galactics Federation said
it said resembling uh resembling B say
resembling kind of funny yeah put right
there in yeah just for it's it's funny
the way they play those tricks host of
msnbc's Morning Joe questioned whether
the blemishes were magic marker blood or
something that may have been exacerbated
by Trump slamming his hands in the table
during his defamation trial surrounding
statements he made about writer EEG
Carol what I love about this is that uh
first uh we here at timcast when I saw
the story you know the first thing I did
was I scrolled past it
I saw I saw a story and says what is
wrong with Trump's hands i h and then I
kept going and then I read an oped from
the Covington Catholic kid Niam I'm like
oh here's an not B I'll read about that
story that matters to me and uh but this
is picked up by all the cable outlets
and so finally when I started realizing
everybody's talking about this I Google
searched blisters on hand and golf
blisters is like one of the first things
I found and I was like oh and Trump goes
golfing he goes golfing all the time
uhuh it's like or it could be this other
thing that we like better it
assassinates character also you know
it's no it's like you mentioned the EEG
EEG Carol trial that's going on and of
course they would come up with syphilis
because it links it to something you
know sexually untoward and then it
almost like meta verifies her stupid
narrative look Democratic strategist
James Carell didn't mince words they
don't look like cuts to me I think
there's a good chance this man has the
clap okay uh that that's goria and I do
not believe that causes blisters on your
hands but I don't know for sure he he
said Wednesday on the politicon podcast
noting he consulted a number of doctors
who all came to the consensus that Trump
has secondary syphilis though he didn't
identify the doctors and added the
disclaimer that the photos may have been
doctored holy crap okay so syphilis has
phases and secondary I I could be
totally wrong but I think secondary
syphilis is like a cple a year or two
out or something like that yeah it's a
while later I the only thing I really
know about syphilis is that n had
syphilis and didn't it I think it killed
them cuz they used to drink Mercury how
do they get away with writing stuff like
this and calling conservatives
conspiracy theorist Beyond me that's
such a good question well they're a cult
you know what I mean like so you have
post liberals former Democrats
disaffected liberals conservatives all
of us disagreeing on policy but the one
thing we agree on is these people are
crackpot cultist weirdos and so they'll
call all of us conspiracy theorists when
we say stuff like yeah you guys are you
guys are crazy but that that's it and
and you ask how do they get away with it
well how do they get away with a woman
claiming that 30 years ago Trump raped
her in the Bergdorf or whatever and
Trump and Trump's like there's no
evidence I've never met the woman I have
no idea what she's talking about and
they're just like he you're liable
anyway so whatever it's crazy who's
going to want to live I I'm sorry just I
would not want to live in any of these
places these cities we're we're we're
really getting New York is beyond the
Communist dut uh communist dystopia
sense where quite literally a a stranger
you've never met I think Trump they're
they're saying that he knew EEG Carol
whatever and there like a photo of them
at a party at the same time and Trump's
like I i' been to a bunch of parties
with a bunch of people I don't know who
this person is he went to every party of
the socialite set and he was probably
the most well-known person in most of
those and multiple women came to take
pictures with him right it something
yeah so one day you're going to get sued
by someone you've never heard of
claiming that you I don't like in this
instance for Trump raped her or whatever
or sexually assaulted her this woman
just
clearly everybody everybody agrees is a
whack job yeah it's a whack job but this
is this is the the current state of
American politics and it's funny because
I'm like guys I'm going to say it civil
war if there's not going to be one if
there's not going to be one and maybe
not it's just social collapse and so
maybe it won't ever be like Mass scale
fighting over control of the government
or anything like that it'll just be you
know somebody who lives in Iowa doesn't
View Missouri as their neighbor anymore
I feel like part of the time timing of
the story has to do with the fact that
they were at melania's mom's funeral
today it's like there can't be any
moment where the trumps seem like a
sympathetic family they're just going
through something actually we have to be
reminded that we we being mainstream
media hate him at all times at all costs
uh and I find that to be really ugly I
think people become disenchanted with
consuming news that's basically fueled
on speculation and hate if you actually
look at any of the uh the websites that
can show you the views of these websites
that of other websites like a refs or
Sim rush it shows that their views have
went down significant it's a significant
drop in CNN and all the mainstream
because a lot of viewers were stressing
if you look in the comments CNN them
even removed the comment section off
their websites because of this it's was
like why are they still talking about
Trump they said you don't even have to
bash Biden we just want to know what our
active president is doing they were more
concerned about Trump I remember when he
was just taking the high road and being
very quiet they were criticizing him for
golfing saying that he was no longer uh
caring about the audience like bro I
thought he is impress anymore so this is
the nature of the media Donald Trump is
forced into an emergency bunker by
far-left insurrectionists and the media
made fun of him and called him bunker
boy I'm like so when the far-left
interfered in the official proceedings
of the United States by firebombing the
White House that's not an Insurrection
but when J Sixers interfere in the
Electoral count that's an Insurrection
I'm like either the both insurrections
or or neither are insurrections nether
pulling a fire alarm as
well alarm yeah that guy is not just
locked up well and he has great ideas
for reparations now too that he was
talking about today like he got a new
promotion yeah I I I think you know I
what I was just saying about social
breakdown there's a big story right now
where uh Texas has begun arresting
illegal immigrants I love this story in
defiance of uhing him today oh yeah yeah
yeah and uh I'm telling like we we grain
of sand being added to the Heap at some
point the federal government either has
to admit it's been defeated look I'll
put it this way by Texas which is kind
of perfect well that's it the dam has
broken it it the dam is broken okay we
we are not necessarily looking at Fort
Sumpter although I wasn't the one who
made this point I can't remember they
made this point um I think it it might
have been like Benny Johnson I'm not
sure that uh yeah I think it was Benny
he was saying that the federal you know
start of the first Civil War first Civil
War the federal government is saying
this is our territory the south is
saying no it's not and there's a
standoff nobody really dies but we call
that the start right now in Texas the
federal government is saying uh uh Texas
is breaking the law is breaking federal
law barring them from access to the
river and they have no authority to
enforce border issues and Texas is
saying we're going to do it anyway the
dam is broken because now there's one of
two scenarios the first scenario is the
federal government loses has no
Authority no control and the confidence
in the federal government's ability to
enforce the border is gone Arizona makes
it the next move which they should be
doing I mean with ktie Hobs they won't
if the federal government loses here and
they are not able to enforce with Force
the States win and that diminishes the
power of the federal government
substantially to where other states will
start taking similar action how do we
know this is going to happen because
when California started defying federal
law with their Sanctuary cities and
Sanctuary States we then saw the
emergence of gun sanctuaries where
several jurisdictions started saying we
will no longer enforce these federal gun
laws so a Texas for instance has
completely ued the uh ban on suppressors
and they say uh uh in and and fact check
me before you go and buy suppressors but
my understanding is if you're in Texas
you can buy a Texas suppressor and they
don't adhere to federal law so it's the
it's the ATF who have to come and stop
you from doing it the other path is the
federal government decides the only way
to assert their Authority and prevent
the breakdown of confidence is to by
force stop the Texas National guarden
Law Enforcement from prohibiting them
that would mean an escalation of force
from federal law enforcement against
Texas National Guard or police well
what's interesting too though is the
Border agents that Biden deploys what
they typically do is uh they're not
there on the on the line dealing with
the Border they're mostly just
processing people that's all they're
doing so the National Guard went in and
said you know we're going to actually
close the border here and the law that
Texas passed was interesting because it
said that it's illegal to enter ta enter
Texas uh Crossing an international
border illegally so they made being they
made illegally crossing the border IL
illegal again thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net